-Welcome to the launch zone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, for this game, we're
gonna play you a popular song.
When you think you know it,
stomp on your foot pedal
to launch the mic
in the air like this.
-Whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
Nice!
-If you catch the mic
and correctly name that song,
your team gets 1,000 points.
If you drop the mic
or get it wrong,
someone else can buzz in.
Okay. Round 1 is called
Classroom Instruments.
The band will play a popular
song on toy instruments.
When you think you know it,
get ready to launch that mic.
Band, are you ready for this?
All right.
Here is the first song.
Get ready.
-Uh-oh.
-Two, three.
♪♪
-Oh.
-Dang it.
-♪ So fresh and so clean ♪
-You nailed it.
-Dang it!
-Thank you.
That's it, band.
Let's hear it out.
-♪ I'm just so fresh ♪
♪ So fresh and so clean, clean ♪
-I love it. Nice job right there
for 1,000 points.
-That was so fast.
-Okay.
-Ready?
You know how it's playing now.
I can see
you're already getting --
Your competitive juices
are flowing.
Let's hear another one.
Here we go.
-Two, three.
♪♪
-"Ring of Fire."
-That's correct.
"Ring of Fire."
♪♪
-What is that?
♪ I fell in to a burnin'
ring of fire ♪
Let's hear the final song
for this round.
Get ready.
-Two, three.
♪♪
-♪ Havana, ooh na-na ♪
-Yes, that is correct.
-How?
-Chloe, you're killing it.
You are killing it right now.
Crushing it right now.
-Smoking them.
-Oh, my gosh.
It's 3,000 to nothing.
It is time for Round 2.
It's okay.
There's lots of thousands
of points coming up. Get ready.
This -- Round 2 is called
Put a Ringtone On It.
Okay, we're gonna play you
a popular song
in the style of a '90s ringtone.
Here's our first song.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You caught the mic.
-[ Vocalizing ]
What is it? What is it?
-You're very close.
-Oh, my God. I don't know.
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't know.
-Go. Go. Simu's --
-♪ I'm a sucker for you ♪
♪♪
-[ Vocalizing ]
Very nice.
[ Laughter ]
Let's reset your mics.
Good job on that one.
That's partners right there.
All right, now --
-That's how I know most songs,
by the way.
[ Mumbles ]
-Yeah. Let's hear another one.
Here we go.
♪♪
-Ohh.
-♪ A jitterbug ♪
-Yes, but what's
the name of the song?
-What's the name of the --
It's not "Jitterbug"?
The name of the song
isn't "Jitterbug"?
[ Laughter ]
-The name of the song
is not "Jitterbug."
-[ Mumbles ] "Wake Me Up Bef--"
"Wake Me Up" by Wham!
Yeah. "Wake Me Up."
-Yeah, all right.
"Wake Me Up Before You Go-Go."
That's right.
-Okay. We accepted that.
-I was gonna give you
"Jitterbug."
You were totally right.
-What?
-You can't step on it
as you're going back.
You've got to be careful.
These are dangerous.
-I just love doing it so much.
-These are 50 pounds each,
by the way.
They're very dangerous.
I want to go see the concert
where you guys sing "Jitterbug"
and [Mumbles]
Okay, here's the last one
for the round.
Here we go.
-Oh!
-"Africa."
-That's correct, right there.
Oh, my gosh.
It's a barn-burner.
Yeah.
[ Vocalizing ]
All right. Nice job, Simu.
This is the final round
of this challenge.
It's called
One Second Wonders.
We're only gonna play you
one second of a song, okay?
So get ready to stomp.
Look at you.
Chloe, look at you.
[ Laughter ]
You're getting --
All right, come on.
Getting geared up.
All right, let's hear
the first track.
Here we go.
-♪ Ella, ella ♪
-Oh, yeah.
-"Umbrella" by Rihanna.
-Yes, that's correct,
right there.
-♪ Under my umbrella ♪
Wow, that was fast.
That was fast.
One second on there.
I love it.
Let's hear another
one-second song.
-♪ Let's go, girls ♪
-"Man, I feel Like a Woman."
-Oh! Shania!
-♪ Man, I feel like a woman ♪
-I didn't know that one.
-That is exactly right.
All right.
Very, very close right now.
Anyone's game.
It is time for the last song.
For this one,
we're only gonna play
a quarter of a second
of the song.
-What?
-And it's worth 5,000 points.
Good luck on this one.
Here it is.
-♪ Galileo ♪
-Ohhh.
-Yeah.
-"Bohemian Rhapsody."
-That's correct, Adam Lambert.
-That's not fair!